quel est l'endroit o on va passer la
plus grande partie de sa
viere peut plus
j comment imaginer é peuttre imp temp
de J plaisir et dans ce que je vais
faire je vais être heureux d'ailleurs
peut-être même à l'instant où je vous le
dis vous vous dites non c'est pas
possible la face qu'est-ce qu' vous
raconte et bien nous on y croit
fortement donc ce que je vais vous
raconter pendant ces 15 minutes c'est
pas la vérité c'est simplement ce que
nous on a envie de vivre pour se donner
un maximum de chance que chacun d'entre
nous puisse venir bosser tous les jours
avec plaisir et être heureux donc c'est
surtout pas la vérité c'est ne retenez
pas tout ce que je vais vous dire parce
que c'est ce que nous on a envie de
vivre peut-être que vous vous vivrez
différemment et peut-être que vous le
verrez vivre différemment dans dans les
boes dans lesqu vous
la responsabilité du bonheur dans dans
une entreprise elle appartient à qui à
l'entreprise assurément mais pas
seulement le bonheur dans l'entreprise
il appartient à chaque collaborateur et
je vais essayer en TR points de vous
expliquer pourquoi le premier point qui
est pour moi le plus structurant et qui
va à mon avis fonder tout le bien-être
que vous allez pouvoir vivre dans une
boîte c'est est-ce que moi
collaborateur comment je suis aligné
avec moi-même est-ce que quand je viens
bosser je suis le même que quand je
rentre à la maison est-ce que tous les
matins je mets un costume une panoplie
que je retire le soir est-ce que je suis
moi-même avec mes forces avec mes doutes
avec mes Fabl avec mes qualités parce
que si demain vous venez bosser dans une
boî avec une panop vous allez vivre que
de frustration que d'inquiétude que de
REM que
d'incpréhension donc c'est s que c'est
pas facile de comment je peux faire pour
être moême pour maccepel que je suis et
que les
autresaccept que je suis mais ça pour
moi c'est le fondement de la be du
bonheur de chacun le deè point pourêre
moême il faut un deè truc
moi collaborateur comment je crée le
climat de confiance autour de moi pour
que l'autre quand il vient échanger avec
moi il puisse être en confiance et être
à son tour luimême si moi je ne crée pas
ce clim de confiance c'est impossible
pour l'autre d'être lui-même donc ma
deuxème responsabilité en tant que
collaborateur c'est celle-ci je je vais
vous parler de très égoïement de moi sur
deux exemples ça fait 24 ans je fais du
recrutement depuis 24 ans j'essaie de
faire en sorte que chaque candidat que
j'ai en face de moi soit lui-même moi le
test de vous avez 5 minutes pour me
vendre le stylo ou je suis content j'ai
réussi à le piéger ça ne m'intéresse pas
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est comment je
peux faire en sorte que le candidat se
sente bien heureux au moment de
l'entretien pour qu'il soit lui-même que
je puisse savoir si correspond au valeur
que nous cherchons pour venir dans notre
entreprise le deuxème point je n'aime
pas ces initi DRH je ne les aime pas
parce que chaque fois que je les mets ça
met une barrière dans la relation à
l'autre sur mon ilcr Fabrice lard sur
mon adresse ma il écitri je travaille
dans les ressources humaines donc il
faut que moi collaborateur je crée le
climat de confiance pourà chaque fois
que je discute avec quelqu'un il soit
confiance pour pour me parler avec ses
forceses faiblesses ça c'est hyper
structur et enfin le trè point
dans une entreprise on a tous notre
destin en on doit tous être en prier
acteur de son bonhe il faut pasend de
l'reprise des ches bien
faireonsabit c'est moi que je mon bonhe
je fais 8 20 tous les JS Jes Mang j'ai
frustrationose pas je va
VI que je fais moi pour être acteur de
ce bonheur et seulement après
l'entreprise intervient et c'est
maintenant que je vais vous parler de ce
qu'on essaie de de mettre en place mais
vous voyez bien que le collaborateur
dans le bonheur le bien-être il a une
responsabilité colossale sans ça c'est
pas possible de prétendre au bonheur
dans l'entreprise alors pour
l'entreprise sa première responsabilité
c'est de le dire si on veut et si on
croit fortement au bonheur et au
bien-être de ses collaborateurs marquer
la première stratégie du projet France
chez nous c'est marqué ensemble engagé
et heureux c'est fort de sens et de
conséquence ça ve dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'on prend une décision ça passe sur le
Tami ensemble engagé et heureux mais si
on l'écrit pas ça peut pas fonctionner
c'est notre première stratégie avant la
satisfaction des clients pourquoi parce
que si vous vous n'êtes pas bien dans
une entreprise comment voulez-vous vous
occuper correctement de vos clients ça
marche pas ça vous le voyez même quand
vous faites
es dans grpe pas for commentorter qu
chose de positif groupe
bien
pour avance bien dans ce sensous
les bien estce que je viens tous les
jours avec
plaisir jus une
FO 2017 de faire FO par
deè point le recrement super important
je vous par tout à l'heure
personnalité il est extrêmement
important
quer non pas des diplômes je suis désolé
fait belles études mais ça va super
important des personnalités nous on de
diplôzous leier c'est la du sport quand
Mme mieux le deè la passion du sptif leè
c'est la passion deautre exp justeant
donc c'est hyper important et le et le
4è c'est l'esprit d'entreprendre et
c'est ça qui va être très important pour
nous donc le bonheur au travail il passe
aussi par les collaborateurs que l'on
recrute autre point peut-être que vous
avez déjà entendu parler du principe de
subsidiarité peut-être que ça c'est un
terme barbare que vous allez découvrir
c'est quoi le principe de subsidiarité
c'est la capacité à prendre les
décisions au plus proche de ses
conséquences qui peut mieux que le
collaborateur qui est au plus proche de
ses conséquences prendre les meilleures
décisions pour lui son équipe ses
collègues ses clients personne d'autre
certainement pas celui qui est dans le
au 10e étage donc il faut que nous on
crée ce schéma qui permet à chacun
d'entre nous de pouvoir prendre les
meilleures décisions en plus ça nous
permet d' tragile et flexible parce que
ça veut dire que la décision elle ne
tombe pas du haut on n'attend pas
qu'elle elle tombe du haut c'est le
collaborateur qui ose et ça pour le
bonheur du collaborateur c'est quelque
chose d'excellent je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez mais c'est quand même
plus sympa que vous soyez acteur de la
décision bien sûr que vous la faites
challenger mais c'est quand même plus
sympa d'être acteur que d'entendre dire
est-ce que tu peux me rendre ça pour
dans une demi-heure est-ce que tu as 3
jours peux me rendre ça est-ce que non
c'est pas comme ça qu'on doit
fonctionner donc c'est c'est important
que la décision vienne du collaborateur
et qu'elle se fasse challenger ça c'est
très très important le 4è point la
gestion de
parcours ça fait 24 ans que je quat long
j'ai fait 12 métiers 12 métiers dans des
domaines totalement différents et bien
nous c'est ce qu'on veut continuer à à
faire vivre mais pas de la façon dans
laquelle je l'ai vécu je m'explique
jusqu'à maintenant on avait gestion de
parcours bien établie c'estàdire que si
vous n'aviez pas fait ce métier là vous
ne pouviez pas faire le suivant et comme
vous n'aviez pas fait le précédent bah
pour le suivant c'était fichu ça c'est
cétait la première difficulté la
deuxième c'était de se dire alors vous
vous êtes en logistique vous voulez
aller en magasin en marque non ça c'est
pas possible vous allez rester en
logistique et là on est en train de
déciloter tout ça de décloisonner ce que
l'on veut c'est que maintenant les
compétences les talents les aptitudes et
la motivation de chacun créent le
parcours mais plus les métiers que j'ai
fait précédemment et surtout pas le silo
dans lequel j'étais je m'explique il y a
pas très longtemps on a une gestion pay
qui avait de belles compétences dans le
web marketing gestionnaire pay ça na
rien à voir avec le web marketing d'une
marque elle est partie dans le web
marketing ça il y a 2 ans on aurait dit
non c'est pas possible je sais pas donc
voilà ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est de
déciloter de permettre à chacun un
nouveau champ des possible autre chose
qu'on essaie de faire pour continuer à
donner un maximum de chance de
développer le bien-être et le bonheur
c'est ce qu'on appelle le multirôle je
vais prendre un exemple très concret
jeis mon métier de vendeur depuis 30 ans
j'aime bien ce métier je suis pas
forcément mobile mais j'ai envie quand
même de faire d'autre choses et bien ce
qu'on va permettre demain à nos
collaborateurs c'est de se dire quelles
sont tes compétences et talents reste
sur ton métier à 80 % et les 20 % autres
tu vas les donner à un service comme la
DAF l'informatique une marque et cetera
ça c'est quelque chose qu'onait pas
avant donc là on essaie de s'ouvrir un
nouveau champ des possible pour que
chacun puisse pu peut-être lancer ou
relancer son
[Musique]
parcours autre point et ça celui-ci j'ai
dis des choses hycturant celu est
fondamental on doit rentrer dans une
transformation de la posture managériale
ça veut dire que la façon dont on man
son équipe aujourd'hui elle doit être
différente de celle qu'on a fait hier on
peut plus fonctionner comme on a fait je
m'exlique manager auour' lui doit se
doit se mettre dans une situation et une
position de coach ça veut dire quoi un
coach un coach c'est celui qui va aider
l'autre à cheminer qui va lui faire un
effet miroir qui va l'aider à prendre
les bonnes décisions mais qui va pas lui
imposer ça c'est quelque chose aussi de
très important alors bien sûr que là il
va falloir qu'on a un certain nombre de
formation à la fois pour les managers
pour qu'il deviennent coach parce que
quand vous avez pendant 20 ans un animé
de façon plutôt descendante même si
c'était participatif c'est hyper hyper
difficile à faire ça
et ce que je souhaitais aussi dire c'est
que on sait que c'est pas facile pour
les managers de passer de manager à
coach mais il faut absolument qu'on
arrive à transformer à passer ce virage
parce que il y va du bien-être et du
bonheur de tous les
collaborateurs ça c'est fondamental et
moi je ne souhaite plus qu'on dise dans
la boîte en tout cas en France euh alors
tu veux prendre un risque vas-y he par
contre tu plan pas mais non ça ça peut
pas marcher vous vous rendez compte si
vous commencez comme ça à à à parler à
votre collaborateur mais c'est déjà fini
le truc il va il va rien oser du tout
donc il faut qu'on arrive aussi à à
changer à changer tout ça et puis je ne
pourrais pas vous parler de bonheur et
de bien-être sans l'environnement de
travail l'environnement de travail
devient un allément essentiel une
composante essentielle au bien-être
c'est sûr que quand vous travaillez dans
un bureau pas de plafond vous voyez pas
la lumière du jour il y a jamais la
bonne chaise la bonne table bah c'est
sûr que ça ça à venir bosser tous les
jours avec plaisir et et avec bonheur
donc je sais que nos cousins de l ro
Merlin sont
ici on a on a un nouveau site qui
s'appelle le Jardin des Plantes à Lille
si jamais vous voulez venir le voir vous
êtes les bienvenu parce que on a fait un
super travail de de lumière naturelle
pour que franchement s' sont bien il y y
a une salle zen une salle de repos de
sieste enfin voilà c'est mais parce que
si on veut vivre le bonheur et le
bien-être il faut qu'on estit jusqu'au
bout de la stratégie sinon ça marche
pas donc si vous posiez la question de
est-ce que vous vous croyez au bonheur
ben bien sûr j'y crois à fond ça fait 2
ans que je suis dans cette dans cette
mission bien sûr que j'ai j'ai j'ai
envie qu'on le vive à fond mais vous
dire que c'est vert tous les jours c'est
pas vrai ça serait vous mentir vous dire
que tout le monde a changé que les
collaborateurs osent sont eux-mêmes que
les managers sont devenus tous des coach
c'est pas vrai on est en train d'y
travailler ça nécessite beaucoup de
patience d'écoute de bienveillance et
puis surtout en cas de difficulté
économique est-ce qu'on va revenir au
habitudes ancienes ou est-ce qu'on va
tenir que nousous sommes maintenant
depuis un bon moment c'est là on va voir
si la force de notre projet elle est
vraiment là et puis je vous dit je vousi
je vous ai dit que je n'aimais pas mes
trois initiales RH en fait j'en aime de
RH our' même mais ça peut vouloir dire
aussi rendre heureux merci à
vous